ma ragazzi avevo dato dei compiti per
oggi per caso si professoressa c'erano
sette esercizi
io non ti 10 per seguire le cose note le
vacanze sono stata da dio l'acquisto di
caricata così passerà un anno a studiare
comune sta per andare in banca saper
andare al misfatto di nuovo no no ti
prego prof
noi petroff utilità dovuto fare i conti
ring agi
dai un foglio che al dizionario dai prof
ma che mi spegnere gli open ma ha
cambiato colore no vabbè addomesticare
suo parrucchiere jessica sei di nuovo in
ritardo possa sapere il motivo ho già
deciso
studierò di volta in volta almeno 5 ore
al giorno dopo cioè il 50
chi si ricorda il teorema di vita
piuttosto quel caso strano se maggiore
meno base minore diviso due
sì posso ma la cistite allora domani
l'ho mai litro morta prof
domani andrà
no
o prossimo perché io ho preso è lei che
era sotto lo stesso monti cappelle 5 non
che io volevo 5 e niente siamo all'ora
di religione quindi si fa festa cioè
sarà che gioca poco con gol salute o pro
saluta ogni subito quel telefono prendi
al buono più che il lasciamo
stare apre il libro pagina 25 stoppa
propri il libro l'ha mangiato il quale è
quello che stava male o proprio quando
va in bagno io vado se non era sposato e
uscito un video di marino no vabbè adoro
da lei e poi c'è a valutare un
fazzoletto
con l'aiuto astuto ogni giorno e lei
dichiarato volta che mi prenoto va fiume
nei vari cross scusa angelica ma come
mai fogli io avevo dovrebbe tutti in
giro dai compagni e io non so come
scrive asaro non se n'era andata mostro
torna top ten su quello che voglio ha
capito prof
quello che mi pare io